amber your your costume in the film is  absolutely stunning why don't we take a  look at it first then talk about whether  you were happy with this costume or not  I think we have a picture right here  [Applause]  yeah so what I mean was that obviously a  very beautiful costume very stunning  costume probably not the most  comfortable thing in the world what do  you mean by that  that wearing one now but anyway that's  when I go out but the other thing is  when you're in a costume like that I've  had just tiny experience just in  shooting sketches but not by being a  movie set you're in you have to be in  that thing for a long period of time  yeah like eight eight months or so  wouldn't we know when I saw it and they  room the other day I mean I think I  didn't get that thing out of this room  right it just horrified you to even see  I can't even look at it well this way do  you want it out of your life I'll take  it  it's all your  you  [Applause]  you